you play on Australian a character on
love so are you at all worried about
being typecast or pigeon-holed
as you know you can only do Australian
absolutely I'm terrified this show is
over now love it's come to an end which
is very bad for me because it was my job
and it's how I got my money so it's what
I did all day and my living and now it's
over
so I do need to get more jobs wait did
we know you were unemployed when we
booked you on that job this is my job
today but after today I don't yeah it's
still right it's got a little time left
but yeah casually we dip into the
unemployed pool yeah and I'm so grateful
to be here yeah yeah but so I did want
to use the show tonight as a showcase
for some of my other characters just to
prove how versatile I can be oh sure
yeah well maybe we should see one you
have a other character that you do I
have one and I'll show it to you right
now it's called the understanding
Scotsman the understanding Scotsman
that's right
okay you can just sort that into any
movie Spielberg Soderbergh I can't think
of any other directors okay do are you
ready okay this is the understanding
Scotsman yeah I understand
that's your one give it just sit for it
as a backup you have one others oh yeah
you know that you can it's not an
original character but I'm not sure if
you know they're making a they they're
gonna try to make another Sex in the
City movie and unfortunately Kim
Cattrall is not going to take part in it
she's not going to be in it she doesn't
want to be in it so people are saying
maybe it should be Sharon Stone as
Samantha the sort of the sexy one but I
think it should be me you want to take
over the Samantha role yes do it I can
do it you sure because you don't seem
like her at all I'm pretty much exactly
the same but do you want to say yes I do
want to say this is it
[Applause]
oh my god you got the part
you